and we're really excited because james
paxton starts his second chapter with
the mariners this evening the big maple
just underweight no score and here is
first baseman jose abreu last year's
american league mvp now the 2-2 to brayu
swing and a miss and a slider down and
in for strike three and that will retire
the side welcome back big maple back to
the seattle mariners a one two three top
of the first inning with a couple of
strikeouts of robert and jose abreu way
to go
james haxton nice to have you back lucas
giolito starts the second trip through
the white sox rotation this evening he
threw five and a third on opening day
against the angels
here comes seeger a veteran third
baseman
he's their number three hitter
a ball in two strikes on seeger
swing and a miss on a changeup strike
three he's out mariner's done
so giolito matches paxton with a one two
three first
and two strikeouts after an inning
nothing nothing from seattle
a chance here to grab the lead as andrew
vaughn steps in here's the stretch and
the o2 on the way fastball misses down
and away for ball one one ball
and two strikes mariners in the white
sox no score if you just tuned in we're
in the top half of the second
the sox are threatening monkat is on at
third base
with one out and now time is called and
paxton
looks like there's something wrong with
james he's to the back side of the bound
bending over
oh my goodness after throwing that last
pitch here comes scott service out of
the dugout along with a trainer
and this is not what we wanted to see
james paxton looks
a little disgusted right now with
being in pain and he's going to have to
leave the ball game oh my goodness after
throwing a pitch to andrew vaughn
here in the top half of the second
james got off to a great start a one two
three first runner at third one out
through a pitch to vaughn and you could
see
james in pain
he felt something right away and
terrence immediately out to the
mountains you see him walking over the
back of the mound
monkatta at third vaughan takes
downstairs it's ball four
and charge that to paxton runners at
first and third for the sox mariners
nothing white sox nothing that'll bring
up catcher
zach collins
middlemen back at double play depth
collins hits one in the air
right center it's deep at the 380 marker
that baby's gone
that is a three run homer zach
collins
three nothing in the second
here's jose marmalejos
with two out and nobody on
there it is
sorcery
in the second inning for lucas giolito
he just struck out the side
he has struck out five in a row all
swinging
eating the right fielder
he popped up on the first pitch of the
ball game popped up a weak pop up in the
infield caught by j.p crawford
there's your one pitch breaking ball
hung and a soft liner to the right of ty
france he makes a semi-sliding catch
for out number one
hanager the batter
first and third infielder double play
depth here's the 1-0 to mitch
giolito holds now comes to the plate pit
swing on line drive base hit left field
fraley will score arizona board it's 3-1
white sox mitch hanigar coming up big
with his second rbi of this young season
and already his seventh hit welcome back
mitch henniger
see how they deal with ty france now
who's a dangerous hitter
pitch swung on driven deep to left it's
got carrie down the line it's got a
chance into the corner off the glove in
fair territory off the glove of vaughn
jp scores hannigan will hold at third an
rbi double for ty france and here come
the mariners it's 3-2 chicago in the
third
kyle struck out on a 1-2 pitch first
time up
comes up empty
this game is tied
and that'll bring up
taylor tremell he cade on three pitches
back in the second inning
swing in a miss strike three
eight strikeouts for gia lito
vaughn
walked and scored in the second will bat
andrew vaughn right center field his
first major league hit up the alleyway
mercedes into third and save that
baseball for young andrew vaughan
with the double in the fourth inning
on this april the sixth
[Applause]
it's up to garcia
laori batting from the right side
and margavitch is trying to keep the go
ahead run over there third the one
nothing pitch swung on fly ball into
right field backing up his hannigan to
the warning track mitch back pedal some
more he's there to make the catch and
margaret
works out of trouble here in the top
half of the fourth two left on for the
white sox we go to the bottom of the
fourth still tied
robert
and struck out twice
the pitch
is hit a ton to left
and it's going to go
two-run homer
luis robert
sox lead 5-3 his first
the white sox five in the mariners three
and that'll bring up third baseman
johann manchada
the 01 pitch swung on fly ball softly
hit left field charging in fraley dives
and he makes the catch
holy smokes what a grab by jake fraley
robbie montana the base hit and that
will retire the side sinking liner into
left field braley diving in
and on his belly slides on the grass
what a catch by fraley to end the inning
sox get a couple
it will be up to madrigal with two outs
sadler trenton put an end to the top of
the six there's three and two two out
runners at second and third a pit swing
and a fly ball easy fly ball right field
coming in about five steps shoulder high
catch mitch hanniger that'll do it for
the sox in the six they strand two we go
bottom six
evan white tonight is struck out twice
on a 2-2 pitch in a 3-2 pitch
the pitch by lucas swinging a miss
he's got 10 strikeouts tonight
the batter will be dylan moore who just
came in to play left for the injured
jake fraley
white sox lead by two one two fastball
inside corner
strike three called
and the mariners strand a couple
jose abreu two on first and third no
outs
sadler in trouble here in the seventh
abreu first pitch swing high fly left
field plenty deep to get eaten in
catch made by moore
eaton tags and scores
sac fly abreu it's six to three
and it's andrew vaughn who's had his
best game as a big leaguer with the bat
he has walked twice
doubled for his first major league hit
so three times on base
scored a run in the second
middleton with the pitch swing and a
slow roller seeger to his left goes
short way to second friends for the
force and that will do it we go bottom
of the seventh time to stretch
the bases are loaded and jose's at bad
the pitch to abreu is hit in the air to
left that is number 200
and his second grand slam of the year
ten to three
garcia oh for four
now the set by
misevic swung on ground ball to secret
third has it over the second for one
france's relay to first and it's in time
for the double ploy and that will retire
the side they get hamilton at second and
double up garcia
at first base we go to the bottom of the
ninth inning last try for the mariners
one on and one away
and that'll bring up mitch hanigar
monkatta
zips it over to
first base gilmore scores two outs
and that'll bring up evan white
there's a check swing roller off the bat
of white it'll go to abraham he'll step
on first and liam hendricks never had to
throw a pitch
the white sox have their first winning
streak of the season